You can't please everyone, and that goes double
for people who consider themselves to be hardcore
Disney fans.
More than a few Disney die-hards are up in
arms on Twitter over the trailer for the upcoming
live-action remake of Mulan, which will not
be a musical and will exclude a couple of
key characters.
The beloved 1998 animated original centered
on Fa Mulan, a peasant girl who disguises
herself as a man so that she can enlist in
the Chinese army, in place of her ailing father,
to help defend her country against the marauding
Huns.
At her side on her journey is Mushu, a tiny,
wisecracking dragon who hopes to restore his
tarnished honor by helping Mulan succeed — a
task made more difficult by General Li Shang,
who serves as an antagonist for much of the
film before being won over by Mulan's bravery
and cleverness.
Shang and Mushu are the characters at the
center of the Twitter uproar, as it's been
revealed that neither will appear in the live-action
film — a revelation that didn't sit well
with legions of passionate fans of the original.
"They'll be begging me to come back to work!"
This isn't to say that many of these fans
are going to refrain from buying a ticket.
Disgruntled fans still rage-attending movies
is a common theme among the outpouring of
angry tweets, as illustrated by a tweet from
user @_dearwallflower, who acknowledged that
the version of Mulan featured in the trailer
looks remarkably badass, saying,
"This is the Mulan we obviously wanted, but
Mushu?
Li-Shang?
Music?
I mean, imma go see it regardless, but imma
also be sad."
The sentiment was echoed by user @GoodyButts,
who ran down her complete list of reactions
to the trailer in her tweet:
"Cries watching the #Mulan trailer… listens
to "I'll Make A Man Out of You"… remembers
there won't be musical numbers or Mushu…
cries some more…
REMAINS EXCITED FOR THIS MOVIE."
One user even flat-out stated that they were
predisposed to rage at the idea of a non-musical
version of Mulan, but that the trailer pretty
much won them over, saying,
"I wanna HATE the Mulan remake but the way
she twiddles her sword with her hair flowing
in the wind?
It looks god tier."
Meanwhile, user @MikeMcdonaldii pointed out
that it's unrealistic to expect the same movie.
"So y'all mad that Disney live-action remakes
are just shot 4 shot w/ the animated movies
but y'all mad that this #Mulan has it own
vision from its animated counterpart."
He has a heck of a point.
This May's live-action version of Aladdin,
although it raked in nearly a billion dollars
in worldwide box office receipts, has been
called out by fans and critics alike for being
a by-the-numbers recreation of the original
that doesn't bother to carve out its own unique
vision.
The same complaints have been leveled preemptively
at The Lion King, which uses CGI to render
its characters in live action.
Of course, The Lion King has been blowing
away preview audiences, so it may prove to
be the film that pokes king-sized holes in
those way-too-early criticisms.
Conversely, Tim Burton's recent remake of
Dumbo drew fire for deviating too much from
the original's story.
Ultimately, that film was among the least
successful of the Mouse House's live-action
reimaginings of their classic library.
It's almost as if the Disney faithful simply
have no idea what exactly they want from these
remakes, before or after they've been released,
although that doesn't seem to stop them from
purchasing tickets.
With only the one teaser trailer to go on,
Mulan's creative team appears to be on the
right track.
Actress Yifei Liu looks awesome in the title
role, and the original movie based on an ancient
Chinese legend tells a complex story with
themes relevant to our times, one that will
lend itself well to a more serious treatment
without singing, dancing, and talking dragons.
“You just say the word and I'm there.
Mushu…
And let me say something.
Anyone who's foolish enough to threaten our
family, vengeance will be mine."
The flick hits theaters on March 27th, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about upcoming
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.